foreign  [Music]  [Music]  can I live with you  you said you don't feel very close to  people your age  your other son he needs you as well and  you're at work all of the time has he  been able to talk about the divorce  I've tried to be there for you I've  tried to give you strength what's going  on are you on drugs you think you can  just live your life doing whatever you  feel like  I feel like a complete failure  I wasn't there fan  there used to be so much joy in our  family you give these big speeches about  life and then you abandon us I have the  right to reinvent my life  hello son you came to tell me what a  good dad you are what do you want  Applause  that's my little boy I can't give up on  it  [Music]  foreign  [Music]